a moment but first here with breaking
news he has been on the ground in Israel
working around the clock uh it is now uh
if you can believe it 4:14 a.m. his time
our very own John Roberts uh you and I
were in full agreement I was feeling a
little bad for Brit tonight uh on
Bretton Martha's hour because uh we were
all kind of ganging up on him but not on
purpose obviously we think the world of
him uh we do think the world of him but
uh I think that uh President Biden did
not give the forceful statement about
Iran that many people think that he
should have now here in Israel it's not
that important because Israel knows that
this President is standing Four Square
behind them uh that he uh issued that
declaration that Israel was not
responsible for the explosion at the
hospital which is really what has
inflamed the Tinder Box of the Middle
East and and that's also based on the
global media picking up Hamas propaganda
and spreading it around the world
remember what Church Hill said Sean a
lie gets half halfway around the world
before the truth gets out of bed well
the global media forgot that that lesson
and spread that disinformation from
Hamas around the world and inflamed the
Arab world so now we got to see if that
is going to die down or if it will
continue to be up now you said at the
beginning of your monologue that there's
a sense that something could happen and
could happen imminently here in Israel
we are getting that same sense here's
here's the tea leav so that you can read
them yourself the Prime Minister
Benjamin netan yo and the defense
minister yav Galant visited the troops
on the front line just outside of Gaza
yoav Galant going so far as to say that
if you haven't seen the inside of Gaza
you soon will and then there's what's
happening on the northern border the big
hit the the big threat from Lebanon is
Hezbollah firing off its vast arsenal of
missiles but the Israelis have massed MK
OFA tanks and self-propelled hozers
artillery 155 Paladin or M 109's up
there and and and the only reason why
they would be up there would be to
support some sort of ground incursion
into Lebanon it's not like a massive
force of Hezbollah is going to come
swarming across the border so is there
an operation about to begin in southern
Lebanon as well Rishi sunak the UK prime
minister was here yesterday uh he was
fully supportive Israel when so far as
to say we want you to
win so with all of that in mind is
something imminent we can't say for sure
but the tea leaves would certainly seem
to add up in that direction the real
concern about a ground Invasion beyond
the fact that there would be many
casualties on both sides is what happens
to the 203 hostages that Hamas has been
holding uh if we are to believe what
Hamas has been saying they are in good
health and they have been taken care of
but if Israel suddenly swarms across the
border into Gaza would that put their
lives at risk uh President Biden in a
tweet earlier today said that we are
pursuing every Avenue to bring their
loved ones home that that is the
families of the hostages but certainly a
grounded operation going into Gaza would
put all of this at risk and uh the
threat of escalation definitely
increases as well so we'll be watching
and waiting here from our post in
Jerusalem Sean to see what happens in
the hours ahead John we both have been
to Israel numerous times I've been there
during a flare up i' I've seen uh the
Border towns near Gaza I've been there
I've seen the underground playgrounds
you know bunker playgrounds kids play in
but I also have witnessed and have been
in these tunnels there's a network of
tunnels the money he spent to build
those tunnels that is money American
money that is Israeli money that was
supposed to be used for schools and
hospitals and infrastructure you you are
fully aware you have reported on this
over the years as well why do I have no
confidence and and and I know the
president is pushing this hard he wants
$100 million to go to the Palestinians
well can that include uh the relief of
the hostages can we get something for
this can that include the location of
all the other tunnels so they can be
destroyed so they can't use them in the
future to attack Israelis can there be
some negotiation
here if if Hamas truly cared about the
Palestinian people there might be room
for some sort of negotiation like that
but let's not forget that Israel
believes that Hamas broke into a United
Nations relief and works agency building
and stole Fuel and other materials from
the United Nations so uh Hamas knows how
to do this they know how to steal relief
Aid and if there are truckloads and
truckloads of relief Aid coming into
Gaza and Hamas is the only and sole
power on the ground in Gaza how can you
ever believe that Hamas isn't going to
take at least a portion of that and that
it will use it for its own purposes and
not to keep the Palestinian people safe
and fed all right John you've been doing
a phenomenal job hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else